dans la salle des ouvriers agricoles ils
viennent de plusieurs habitations du
nord atlantique par leur présence ils
portent leur soutien à leurs collègues
de l'exploitation agricole acier aux
lorrains en grève depuis le 15 novembre
des ouvriers qui se sont mobilisés afin
de protester contre l'augmentation de la
charge de travail imposée par la
direction à travers l'acquisition d'une
machine censée alléger leur tâche ce qui
a abouti selon le syndicat cgtm au non
respect de la convention collective qui
les fait cette acquisition pour
soi-disant permettre aux salariés
d'avoir moins de 2 pdb dit y ait moins
de manipulations nous sommes d'accord
mais qu'il respecte la convention qui
dit 500 kg par personne
une tonne d'engrais ces deux personnes
de tonnes d'engrais quatre personnes
trois tonnes d'engrais personnes ont ce
monsieur monsieur thierry arnaud s'amuse
à mettre 3 tonnes d'engrais pour 4
personnes pour déverser au chant ce
n'est pas logique
et ce n'est plus acceptable par les
salariés voilà la trémie cette machine
distribuer l'engrais aux ouvriers qui
ensuite vont le sommet dans les champs
et pour la direction son utilisation
améliore considérablement les conditions
de travail des ouvriers
ça fait sept ans qu'on travaille avec
cette famille qui a une capacité de 3
tonnes si effectivement ça rendu de
salariés plus performants grands
puissent quand on a un système de
travail je dirai qui et je dirai pas
semi mécanique mais qui supprime au
départ qui a supprimé au départ toute
cette manutention de se baisser de se
lever
continuellement
lors de l'application de la
fertilisation à partir de sacs sur ce
point malgré les négociations aucun
accord clair n'a pour l'instant été
trouvé j'ai proposé de suspendre
momentanément d'utilisation de
l'application d'alten manuel à partir de
la trémie en espérant trouver lors de
réunions futures de reprendre les
réunions mensuelles un bon compromis
pour définir un effectif à utiliser à
partir de cette machine il va
interrompre momentanément sa machine et
il remettra des sacs qui veut dire
momentanément également donc s'il veut
dire que nous sommes toujours au même
point puisque
ce n'est pas satisfaisant avec les sacs
il dit respecter la convention alors
pourquoi ne pas respecter la convention
avec son appareil
la mobilisation se poursuit donc à
assier un autre preuve locke le paiement
des jours de grève